fulfilling a campaign promise to enact
extreme vetting president trump signed
an executive order temporarily banning
travel from
seven muslim majority countries in
january 2017
the president's reasoning to make
america safe
and this is the protection of the nation
from foreign terrorist entry into the
united states
[Music]
in the aftermath protests broke out at
airports across the country
as those fleeing violence and trying to
reunite with their families
were prevented from entering the u.s
civil rights organizations branded the
ban
religious discrimination against muslims
legal challenges were successful in
blocking the first two iterations of
trump's travel ban
but in 2018 the supreme court allowed a
third version of the executive order to
go into force
now nationals from 13 countries
including north korea
venezuela and several african nations
are on the list
the travel ban has been particularly
hard for those hoping to escape the
violence in countries like syria
and yemen when the supreme court made
its ruling
those trying to reunite with elderly
relatives were devastated
zaid nagy told us his mother is close to
giving up
she stayed forcibly in jordan for three
years
until the supreme court decision
she she finally said listen
i waited out this this far
i want to go back and die in yemen
that's specifically what she said and to
be honest with you we couldn't say
anything to her anymore
president-elect joe biden has promised
to repeal the travel bans and
increase refugee admissions by 125 000
civil rights groups say that doesn't go
far enough
because the same old same old isn't
going to work anymore
and as hard as we fought against the
trump administration we're going to
fight even harder
against the biden administration because
we expect them to resolve these issues
for those still stuck in the
bureaucratic limbo known as
administrative processing
the incoming administration's promises
if fulfilled
will bring renewed hope president-elect
joe biden says the travel ban
is morally wrong once he takes office he
can rescind the order with the stroke of
a pen
but reuniting families will be a long
difficult and complex process
biden says the policy betrays u.s values
undoing its legacy could take years andy
gallacher al-jazeera
miami florida